yes my mom it's traditionally to happen
over the guests of India cocktails
mother
how are you actually Leslie
we are quite the podcast for you
my mom collected well we'll get to that
anyway this podcast is brought to you by
the ring video doorbell system guys your
doorbell is outdated because it is not a
ring doorbell ring doorbell system is a
video monitoring doorbell that streams
right to your phone via Wi-Fi it is
incredible
is it there are home burglaries every 13
seconds so get yourself a ring video
doorbell system and prevent that from
happening to you right now you can get
$50 off the ring of security kit by
going to ring comm slash Jenna Julianne
that's ring comm / Jenna Julianne also
brought to you by nature box and just
like last time we already ate all our
snacks so we have none to show you but
nature box is constantly adding new and
interesting snacks and they ship it
right to your house they make over a
hundred ridiculously delicious snacks
that are made from ingredients that are
delicious and good for you right now you
can get two bags of snacks for free by
going to nature box common in Julian
that's two bags right now you just like
eat them that's two more bags of snacks
then you might currently have then you
might currently have right now so go to
nature box common enjoin thank you to
respond sirs thank you Scott fais I'm
gonna move sponsor so right now all
right
so mom how are you I'm fine thanks how
are you I'm good um a lot of people have
waited for this podcast for quite a
while yeah Freya long people have been
excited to have you on the cast
finally there's like five dogs and
there's five dogs in the room just in
case you hear some [ __ ] it's just a
bunch of dogs and Jenna decided we
should keep them in in the room where's
my bun cuz it's fun
cousins and their cousins anyway uh so a
quick background on you you are my
mother but you were also a super awesome
talented artist and many different
facets you a lot of people are
interested cuz I've talked about you on
the podcast before and a lot of people
are interested in your TV art career
because I've bragged about it oh that
just reminded me that's what we're going
to make the background of this podcast
the explosion from heroes Hey right
that's a good one
how's it look does it look good my mom
painted this giant mural for the show
heroes and it was like on the back of
the DVD box it's really cool that's what
it is anyway okay so what I want to get
like from the way beginning how did you
even start doing art in TV because I
think a lot of people want to know how
that again it was really totally by
accident um I was an artist and I had
just gone through life always being an
artist um and an old boyfriend called me
when I was in my 20s
I was living in New York City and he
said you want to come down to Biloxi
Mississippi and work on a movie and I
said sure what would I do on a movie and
because I'm an artist and he said just
we'll fly you down here we're going to
put you up in a hotel and you'll be fine
so I knew nothing and she said just you
know make it up as you go so I was so
excited that somebody would fly an
artist somewhere and put them up in a
hotel and give them per diem and so I
did it
and turns out there's a lot an artist
can do on film and television and it
suited my personality a lot better than
being alone in a studio and just
creating for myself in an move so I
really did find a venue through which I
could really express and be part of
bigger projects and it's cool though
because you move like you had you know
so many different projects and points in
your life where you're doing art
from your studio from your house
solitaire and then you you transition in
and out of doing it in movies and TV
very seamlessly like I remember when I
was young you were working on heroes and
you like I watched you on set and you
were just like telling people what to do
and just doing whatever and like you had
everything under control
and I was like you like last week you
were just in your studio painting
portraits and now you're out here like
you know I mean so that meant listening
like a crazy going back and forth what
is your favorite I know you worked on
almost famous right yes yeah what is
your favorite movie you've ever worked
on that TV show of a movie the movie
itself yeah I don't know like experience
always serious mamasan no question
office the office was the craziest most
fun group of people you can ever imagine
I'm still like so upset with myself that
I never got to visit you on set yeah my
parents visited me I said but um why he
Sonny's just heartbroken you can tell I
wasn't an office man when you were
working on the set I was too young I
didn't get in the show yet I saw Leslie
at the grocery store
Stanley Leslie I didn't say hi though he
seemed very just chill shopping I was
just observing him just lay in the wild
yeah yeah so when I when you guys were
little I really wanted to be with you
all the time and so I started a portrait
business out of my house so I could work
while I was with you guys hmm and that
was Incredibles watercolor portraits in
fact we have one in our bathroom though
we have a postcard of a watercolor
portrait signed by Triple H and the
portrait is of me it's amazing you see
that about the right just trying to like
my childhood yeah it's awesome I'll have
more things for the better okay so we're
gonna get more to the art later because
I have Twitter questions from you guys
we're gonna ask my mom and a couple of
them have to do with art but I feel like
we should probably get into your show
and tell ya you got like a lot she
brought in time
can't see there's a duffel bag behind
here yeah and she's wearing this is my
football uniform and the dogs are trying
to steal these stuff to have the dog
slightly Rocky
okay all right the only Jersey wait
honey there's not for years
okay take the okay Eric she's now there
- under her football jerseys now my god
small Jersey from yes number four months
only I was big on the number four back
then wasn't that yeah this is a t-shirt
thing you ain't got design great don't
forget this I have every button from
every team Oh that you've ever been on
anyway
I saved some stuff Julian designed this
t-shirt for his baseball team and this
was Eddie Lopez remember yeah yeah
number 23 mm and so this was his
creation isn't it credible um it's
pretty cool did I do that I did that you
drew it and then it was made into shirts
you four more
oh now you took it off I took it off
desert Lincoln Jersey from your flag
football
this is not it I have a give you a new
job surety of every team they've ever
done I do I saved everything but not
everything in life mm-hmm just
everything about the kids
mmm and this one actually that's my
sister's it's Roxy hey it's our Culver
volleyball that's a really cute shirt
though isn't it I like it's not this you
can meet oh yeah I've talked about an
arm what happened to his arm
I think puppy puppy should your muff but
look at puppy get a dog so this is bear
bear this is my childhood little D bear
bear bear his name is bear bear he
cannot fly I've tested it yeah that was
that was a good
do you wanna yeah well when I was
pregnant with Marlon yeah um Julian was
- yeah and I'm riding in the car the big
belly I can barely reach the wheel
Society and Julian decides cry in his
work he decides that he's going to see
if bear bear can fly and the only really
way to see that is if you just roll down
the window and to hold the bear out but
you know his grip wasn't so good so he
let go of through a bear bear
on the 405 we were driving on bear you
everywhere I just happen to be in the
right lane I turned around Julian had
this weird can you just like you just
glazed over the fact you could turn
around on the 405 how does that work
okay so I yeah wasn't God Duke back
while I was on the 405 so I happened to
be in the right lane so I turned around
and I looked at Julian and there was
something odd about his expression then
I saw the window open then I saw no bear
bear and I lost it because I was just
about to have a new baby and that's hard
enough yeah but the new one wasn't as
good the new baby yeah he was just okay
then
ah he's gonna be Marla's yeah Marla's
not gonna watch him anyway so that we
can just say he's Marlon does watch us
actually and I have to watch what I say
about my own
he says Walker he's the PISA even if he
doesn't watch it he can hack it he can
have your nose it yeah yeah so uh I I
start yelling at him Julian what were
you thinking why wait and you're just
sitting there you're just sitting there
you're just like you didn't even know
what to think having never had a bad
experience in your life really till then
so uh a few minutes go by and I'm like
we're lost we don't have bear bear
anymore Julian says mom I said what
Julian he goes what do you think is bear
bear sitting or standing question I went
on the freeway when the overpass went
the other way went ten miles cuz I had
no idea I just yeah I like I hit the
fast lane - your guilty conscience I was
like is experienced and I was
like I am NOT a better person I can only
do so much
you threw your an air bear out on street
way and now we don't have it and I'm
about to have a baby and everything so
well well that's a story that I've told
before and it's pretty incredible but
this is this is what the story's about
this is literally it was lying down as
it turns out in a puddle on the run
though can you understand on his own two
floppy completely compromised feet one
time I made you a kala Wien costume you
matched bear bear I made for you hmm
Pixar get the [ __ ] I just saw okay so
what have you gotten them I decided then
you know when you were a little older
hey hey hey honey that's not yours
ah that I should get rid of take away
bear bear because you were saying yes
I'm just only at a certain point you get
rid of bear it no so you just went
straight for this guy
Oh with a UH with an S um / no / what /
was the other one oh the dog / was the
Husky yeah it still has slush density
still has slush my we had this little
husky doll it was I think it was like a
beanie baby but bigger ones you'd have
made bigger ones yeah
and it was like marbles size husky doll
and we named him slush and he like I
love slush so much my dad used to tell
me
slush stories at night like wow he did
the slush voice and it was like this
really high-pitched goofy voice that my
dad did while he would pretend he was
being slashed okay really honey here and
uh and I was so into this toy sludge I
like slept with him I took him
everywhere
my dad in addition to bears in addition
about notices this was later on this is
like I was middle school I think right
even high school has slush yeah and my
dad being like the filmmaking guy he is
he made a minute like a short film about
slush and it's like it just film - by
himself and then showed it to me it was
like so funny this is a family picture
no they can't see that okay this is a
birthday card okay Julian made for me
three throwing snowballs at you yes look
at Marlon with his stick
remember that's to get a name name
that's not really he named his
sterically the stick okay now there's
another whole thing of you which is
let's just get art yeah and Julian
started drawing really early is so
talented so talented but he got obsessed
with Batman
so who hast him have you seen that you
made ah oh my god I cannot [ __ ]
believe you still have that of course
but it's so cute you can I don't know
you know is it oh it's a good design
just a hood indicate yeah as one and he
wore it every day for a year
Oh every day every year and you're not
gonna not wear this every day every day
for a year
Julie be careful then after the whole
year was up he decided he needed a
change so he was robbing every day for a
year I don't have that shirt I was
balanced okay I didn't just choose
Batman I went Batman and then rob right
sometimes this robber is just glazed
over as this like oh he's just Robin
he's like half the team I'm sure I have
that shirt somewhere I'll have to look I
also like what I also liked about Robin
is that he didn't need the recognition
to be a great guy he was just out
fighting crime without everyone saying
his name what has he got on the credit
he was doing him he was using all the
right reasons exactly was and also
righto but he gave him any attention so
yeah he was in the show he's the real of
a pen man so at the end of the second
year when you were robbing every single
day you decided to go back to Batman so
you were three years in costume yeah one
year is Batman when yours Robin and then
another year as bad and what do I wear
on my feet another years three total
years of costume Brennan when were on my
feet no no what they had wheels roller
skates on Johnny turtle
rollerskates which you're like I think
you are too and we went on a playdate
for your older sister and you found them
in the closet there and there were sides
woman look at the playdate I found it at
somebody's house I just like you have
them in the closet you put some on it
yeah that's your shoes shoe was it yeah
yeah I don't know why they had a woman's
8 ninja turtle and then you just put a
little date and you really put him on it
I don't take him off and the woman goes
well I guess you can have him and I was
like thank you because he won't take
them off and then he wore them all day
in his stroller in his naps everything
how'd you know break your ankles because
I was coordinated I was Batman twice so
Julian was really into wheels uh yeah
okay I want this this memory lane trip
can continue but I want you to tell a
story about me that I probably don't
remember that might um yeah just go
ahead I know I told you to get stories
together so why don't you pick one from
your pocket book of stress you did say
to write it you're sweet goodness you
didn't write it down yeah ah tell me
when you can hear sorry guys forgive
this podcast for being kind of a [ __ ]
so um what stories did I think of yeah
it's perfect
um well I did want to talk about the art
because you drew so much you just drew
and Drew and drew that one day and you
drew a Batman and Robin I think aunt C
they know they can hold it up I mean
this is just like I wallpapered an
entire wall in our house with your
Batman pictures they're so intricate
they're so beautiful
they're so okay what the hell that is
literally scribbled it's so beautiful
it's like if any and you anyway okay no
more nothin or you can use airplanes but
Batman not
stop that really cool book isn't it yeah
I don't know this is really nice design
I like this grabbing a garbage pizza
that's kind of cool
oh yeah I always had them drawing in
cars crying did I say matter blog at
this come on yeah it's uh clearly just
scribble Scrabble but um it's so
beautiful look at the mouth it is a nice
mouth yeah it's just beautiful that's
Batman and Robin Robin has the ears
anyway what can I say monkey see monkey
drew oh wow oh wow
yep you grew up drawing quite a mom okay
do you have any other artifacts you have
well this was given to you on the day
you were born so I saved it somebody
made it for you that was your Hospital
shirt Oh where's where's your shirt that
you were gonna wear the the Japanese
shirt where is it oh I don't know is it
not here it may not be oh my god that
sure is incredible for sure it is
incredible it's in the other way
whatever you talk about in a vlog or
something okay okay what's this giant
book is this a shrine to my life dad it
was your pre-school graduation book
preschool preschool and it has all your
drawings and your lectures you're all
diktats I'd see where you are Jill here
I'll take this one
your hair was white oh yeah guys I don't
know if I've said that before I was a
completely towhead blonde baby child
well there's I don't know there's some
of the remnants of the blonde hmm you
see it Oh his hair was like white blond
until he was like to the conversation
can we read this yeah
here I'll read it I just want to read it
into the mic so they can hear okay all
right in a conversation with Roxanne my
sister December 1996 Julian how old is
Jon little boy Roxanne he's 40 Lisa I
think he's 41 by now
Julian Batman is 40 mark Sam no Batman
is 60
Julie no 40 Roxanne Batman can't always
can't always ever be 40 he's 60 now
Julian well there's no such thing as
Batman anyway right soon well then what
are you talking about Julian the man
that dresses up as bad backs in so what
you're talking about is Bruce Wayne Lisa
I've got to ride this down Julian right
what down Lisa what you said Roxanne and
Julian what did we say that's pretty
cute honestly I like that really cute
so Mike oh this is a good one this is
good I've told Jenna this Julian mom
what does greater mean mom greeter
Julian yeah like is it a restaurant or
something mom greeter where did you hear
it you know the song sings the tune -
wah go out to greet her when she comes
Julian thought only oh those are about
greater ever yeah that hasn't changed
your school I would say Julian what was
your favorite part of school he would
say lunch oh yeah and then I would say
okay but what was your second favorite
part because it's really sad for you
guys yeah hey lunch I mean how is lunch
not your favorite part of school it's
literally like a 40-minute chill time
where you just grub yep we're gonna put
ears yeah the ears need a little fix
perfect perfect you know what's crazy is
like I love lunch so much back then but
I even have naturebox to love it that
fire segue Julian naturebox guys is our
sponsor this week they deliver awesome
fresh snacks to your door they make over
a hundred delicious snacks guys let me
just read you a couple of the names the
snacks that they have vanilla bean
wafers dark cocoa nom noms and also my
all-time favorite strawberry lemon-aid
stars remember my poem last yeah okay
guys like that poem I know you did write
a poem I wrote a poem about strawberry
lemonade sauce yeah well you know when
you feel so passionately about a certain
type of food sometimes you have to just
express it in a way that you feel best
represents your feeling of that food and
for me that's the strawberry lemon-aid
stars
fruit stars and they have all these
snacks guys and you can select now you
can select how often you receive the
snacks which is really nice
you can receive them every two weeks
once a month every week however you'd
like you can receive five snacks you
receive ten snacks naturebox lets you
completely customize how you get your
snacks plus if you don't like any of the
snacks naturebox will replace it in your
next box for free cannot do that with
all your other snacks guys don't leave
your cabinet without naturebox snacks
right now go to naturebox.com/tyler
annejulien get yourself two bags of
delicious snacks without any of the junk
for free thank you to nature box and our
other sponsor this week is very cool is
the ring video doorbell system we've
recently installed this at our house it
is so cool thank you so yeah it's this
you basically unscrew your doorbell and
you you take the wires that were plugged
into it and you plug it into this and
you mount this up and it has a camera on
it that you can see what is at your
front door dang dog was there I see it
not only can you see it on your phone
stream from anywhere you are there your
curtains you can see it on your phone
but there's two-way audio you can
literally answer the door
from the grocery store if someone's at
your door and they're knocking the ring
video doorbell system will send an alert
to your phone you you go into the app
you pop it up you see the live feed and
you say hi how can I help you and if
it's some creep you're like if it's a
delivery can you join it on the phone
um I don't think it implemented that yet
but you could say can you throw it in
that Bush over there and hide it's not
the one with the burn in Colima Timothy
in it
oh it's Timothy Timothy we are guys
Timothy's still out there
yeah his mommy's feeding him from the
ground he hasn't learned how to fly yet
come on oh I just thought of a great
show Ron let me just finish this really
quick guys right now you can get started
with the ring of security kit the kit
includes a ring video doorbell with the
front door and a ring stick up cam which
we have also installed which is
basically just like a camera you can put
anywhere around your property that you
feel like it would be best served and it
has motion detection so every time there
is motion in the range of that camera
you'll get a little literal push
notification on your phone swipe go to
the app and you can see what caused that
alert there's cloud recording so you can
record anything that that has you know
sets off the alert
it's a weatherproof HD camera
and it keeps an eye on other parts of
your property so if you have the ring
doorbell on the front door you can have
the security camera on the side or
somewhere else where you know you don't
have eyes right now you guys get $50 off
the ring of security kit by going to
ring comm slash Jenna Julianne guys this
is a really really cool thing so check
it out and thank you to both of our
sponsors your sponsors that looks good
on you still Jillian I'm not taking you
off until next year and then I'm gonna
put Robin owe me I'll see if I can find
okay what would be the story I was gonna
tell ya this is so consummate Julianne I
mean I okay so when we lived on Nebraska
which was that's a road not a state yeah
and uh we I lived on the Brassica Street
he wasn't mean we lived on the state of
Nebraska yeah so we lived there I think
it was over 302 or Oh three and I had to
segue into trying to make money without
leaving the house and so I decided to
start this watercolor portrait business
and I got a few Commission's right away
and but I had nowhere I didn't have a
studio so I set up a studio in my
bedroom and it was upstairs and I had to
try to really just focus while the kids
were home and trying to do you know and
trying to do some work so I go
downstairs I'm gonna make some tea I put
the kettle on I go back upstairs to the
movie store I completely get engrossed
in what I'm doing and I forget about the
kettle of course and the kettle you know
runs dry and then the plastic handle on
the top gets so hot it starts melting
because for some reason manufacturer
decided to make a kettle with a plastic
handle it happened it happened yeah um
the mic is a one way so you have to like
turn it there you go yeah anyway um so
it caught fire the plastic caught fire
there's a full-blown fire in my kitchen
but I had loud music going and I was
working and the kids will sit down with
the sickness painting hardcore portrait
yeah
I was just trying to figure out my life
how I'm gonna make money so without
leaving the kids and so Julian Julian
comes to the bottom of the stairs
because he knows he's really not
supposed to come up and disturb me he
goes mom mom there was a fire in the
kitchen but it's okay I put it out I go
okay great Julian thanks so much I
wasn't even really listening like a half
an hour later I go downstairs doesn't
even listen okay oh my god
I don't completely knock whatever and
there's like there's a fire extinguisher
foam all over taking the fire
extinguisher which I'm not even sure how
I knew how to use and put the fire out
but I don't know if you've ever seen the
aftermath of a fire it's just it's like
everywhere powder it looks like whipped
cream or something it's like white all
over everything
but of course I didn't care because you
saved our entire family and a house from
burning down yeah so little little my
perspective was I'm just like goofing
around downstairs and I start to smell
like the burning of something and I'm
like this is weird and then I see like
the flames had like kind of engulfed the
pot so it was like it looked like a
miniature fireball on top of the stove
and I just like I don't know I just
grabbed the fraction as I put it out I'm
like mom I'm sorry but you're not gonna
have tea like the teeth the tea hills
water boiled yeah turned into fire by
the way who starts a tea kettle and then
goes upstairs today you do your drop
that would be me flip I still do that
kind of thing but you're not home so I
can't let it catch fun hmm
um yeah that was pretty incredible thank
you for saving our family and house of
course um no no problem I live there too
so it behooves me to yeah this behooves
all razor
it is be of behave me it behaved me be
his you're trying to find that past him
yeah pass sensitive all right so why
don't we transition into Twitter for a
little bit is that good yeah all right
so we when I went on Twitter with a
podcast account Jenna Jillian pod if
you're not following
we often ask you guys for suggestions
questions whatever and I went on and I
was like what do you guys want to ask my
mom so I've collected I think like
something like 20 questions maybe a
little more maybe less from you guys so
let's start off with a good friend Sonya
hugs so yeah Sonya exam oh wait sorry
hello Exodia my [ __ ] sorry um what is
something okay so we'll go back to here
we go how excited was Julian when he met
Joel Madden um if you're not getting the
joke just let us know we'll explain that
game okay there's a autographed picture
of Joe Madden in the bathroom
Joe Madden like the football guy and
Jenna always thought it was Joel Madden
all managed but it's Joe Madden like of
Good Charlotte yeah uh-huh so yeah don't
yeah not sure Oh excited he was okay
let's be patient
yeah what's something about Julie and is
maimry marbles what is something about
Julian that we that we don't know about
him that might surprise us yep um he
okay yeah just meowing he's me out in
Kermit's meowing he's like Gary about
the snail from SpongeBob - that what was
your first impression of Jennifer um of
me mm-hmm
oh it's good good uh course beautiful
and oh stop it I was in a bar
yes um yeah I Met Your Mama's at a bar I
might have met your mom before I met you
yeah um right cuz I think I walked up
with puppy and you were playing with
puppy yeah yeah we had a quick
conversation yeah yeah yeah eh I met
your mom first
yeah yeah you guys know and I was like
okay who is this woman that's bringing
their dog to a bar right
brought her in there you are my spirit
animal um and then fly far in here yet
here we are weird animals yep well
that's crazy
what's one sorry Julian doesn't want you
to tell on this podcast thanks Sonia
yeah yeah um a story you to whom maybe
he doesn't maybe you don't want to tell
about the haircut Oh God I mean you're
gonna bring that up why I know you know
it won't go oh you're on yes
so it's oh my god so uh Julian I used to
cut all the kids hair but then at a
certain point there was just too many
kids haircut look at all your kids in
your hair not a Barbican Joan herre so I
bad president because I was always
cutting everyone's hair so I started
going you know you cut his hair you got
his make it haircutting chain yeah let's
delegate nurse so uh so they had the the
Clippers memory basically I just
transitioned the buzz cuts like like six
number two number three just shortened
buzzed hair yeah so like it was two on
the sides three over here for you know
the whole thing and they figured I did
so good
but one time Julian goes in the bathroom
with this set and I'm upstairs and I
hear this screaming and he comes out and
he had forgotten to put the little thing
on the actual number clip so you did it
so I just barely went right for the
middle went straight down shaved the
strife shaved a runway this is my granny
back then he anti mohawk it was but it
wasn't exactly centered it was like a
little to the left pretty it's just like
oh there wasn't I say was like your
first day of high schoolers yes yeah
yeah yes it's just made it a really
financially Weatherly and my first day
but I think sophomore year
where was the pressure no it was [ __ ]
Friday's freshman year oh my god there
are a lot of kids you knew from baseball
and different things in school obviously
so but you were hysterical not in a
when you were four weaking out but it
looked so funny that it looks so funny I
couldn't help but laugh so then you got
mad at me for laughing hmm
you worth only one laughing either time
left a tracer so it was just money it
was too funny I was miserable I was like
my life is what is effectively over you
thought your life was over and so you
said what am I get to do what I'm an
adult Gillian really there's only one
thing you can do shave shave the whole
shoot all Julia do that you know went on
and on anyway cut - of course he shaves
his whole head I think his brother did
it because he was so more to find and
the next day goes to school and survived
and he survived not only did it he
survived some I go Julian own it you
shaved your head own it that's it's the
only way to do it the only way to do it
you can't go to school no hi I'm Dominic
yeah so so you went to school and
everyone thought it was the coolest
thing even the moms were like why did
Julian shave his head I know I don't
know I just felt like it and there were
likely so more plural oh I'm you know I
don't think it was the coolest thing I
don't think everyone liked it but it
definitely got a response that I was not
expecting like because like a lot of my
baseball friends were like also in the
first day of high school they were like
ho [ __ ] like you shaved your whole head
that's kind of dope like yeah it turned
out not to be the worst [ __ ] thing in
my entire life so it was and I remember
Roxanne's boyfriend was there too and he
was like pep-talking me up when it when
it happened yeah Victor and he was like
yeah you got a rocket yeah I think there
you go the third guy addicting well that
was good that was good
um mari no sorry I told the story
Sonia made me the group to our good
friend Kristen we met this year at
VidCon pass um what's the weirdest event
or place that you've ever gone to just
because your kids wanted to go
certainly a waterpark I would say that
no adult just willingly just
go to a waterpark in their free time um
yeah that's that and uh even Disneyland
I'm sorry to say it's just the weirdest
yeah yeah
everyone makes fun of me because I
haven't been to the Disney here and I'm
like I don't I want to go but like I
don't really miss Eleanor Rosch - oh
wait in lines and it's just a lot of
crowds look at grown-ups when I've gone
with you guys that are there without
kids and I just thought my yeah yeah
there's a lot of adults though but I
also had a lot of friends who worked on
scenery there so that's great fun to
watch that's great
that's cool yeah mrs. gardiner asks what
is the naughtiest thing Julian ever did
when he was just a little dink
naughty naughty not y'know ah
you naughty one time I was yelling at
you about something there was always
something to yell about mm-hmm too many
kids and nice Kermit you you started
doing this thing with your eyes while I
was yelling at you you really I forget
except remember yeah yeah yeah I did um
it was like very subtle but then you
tried to pick up on it and it was like
yes you acted that way you weren't pet
you weren't my face oh yeah ergo we all
knew the lying face rug same ago see
there's the lying face yeah she was like
on your team for most of the time you
were your whole own team yeah an idiot
on youngest one
well Marlon was my minion for a while
totally he was limited yeah
yes all right well okay now me Murray
Marvel's what is the craziest family
vacation you guys went up oh is this app
to derby girls oh maybe robust my mom
had a euro ven a VW Nero van um the
surfer kind of am like literally
on top you like yeah dad the whole
bottom turns into a bed it was like most
hippie hippie mobile never seen only way
to deal with six kids he can we just
piled in there all the time and like
this one went to baseball practice this
one did their homework on the table I
could stuff the little ones up in the
pop top so I would have don't worry
where they were so then I can help coach
the baseball I'm up there and Minnie has
wanted to go there was like this hole
and you push him up and they couldn't
really get down themselves so that was
good family vacation though we took all
six kids my husband and I took all six
kids to New York City oh my god was that
was and then we rented a minivan we were
eight there's no car for eight so or
eight deep is what she's saying we're
eight people traveling we were eight
people join with you Ted my stepdad and
then six kids yeah that New York trip I
remember you I got you guys all these
treats and anyway oh yeah no we can go
there yeah tonight miniature Statue of
Liberty toys that you get at gift shops
think about our moral square meal marble
marble I hit Marlin over the head with
it in the forehead got him like a
teratoma it was like a giant bulge was
like a golf ball or head yeah that was
those are super big brother a moment of
me because then he was like defending me
to Roxanne sure well anyway that was the
night that we were in New York City for
six or seven nights I think was a whole
week and I said to Ted I'm from New York
and I said if we can't go out to dinner
one night just just go out to dinner you
and me without the kids so we prepared
them with all these goodies and
activities turn the TV on your weapons
and went out for like two hours and this
happened if you come back on Marling's
got a new head on the island at a new
head
Jake Jake and Josh were sleeping under
the coffee table it was pretty
interesting yeah it's good stuff um
can't believe we lived through all that
but what was the mimosa wild wild Stowe
88 asked what was the mimosa mother's
day with Deb Morey like my mother did
today that was like you guys were Moses
and three in the plane of us I live from
Mother's Day I love yesterday and to
have and to spend it with Debian it was
just it's the best I look forward to
that was really cute like you guys
weren't literally just floating in the
pool we claimed elinoz you were just
listening and drinking with us that was
fun yeah that was so fun I don't think
any of us had bathing suits I think we
just went in with her yes yeah we
weren't planning to go in yeah
core deep on X says what's it like
having a hacker for her son was it
difficult to adjust the life of the
hacker troll the hacker troll um I have
to admit that I'm a little like Marlon
yeah oh yeah you guys are very much like
a troll like other people call it lying
we just make [ __ ] up yo yo Marlon did
that all the [ __ ] time he just like
aw man [ __ ]
the answer was no he was like say things
that weren't true she's doing without
any thinking just trolling he's so deep
in the troll but like as a child he did
that
that's crazy crazy I'm a little like
that
yeah all right did you ever have to
ground Julian can i I think you grounded
me um what are the names one of the
names are you're considering for me um
none really
yeah what what am I named after uh your
grandpa my my mom's grandfather Jake hmm
so you wanted to use the J and then I
was driving you were born in Northern
California you were born at Stanford
University hmm we had moved out of New
York City
sold our place and didn't move to LA yet
stopped at my parents house to have a
baby
Jen pink down here when I was like hey
lmao let's get this man from hot oh hey
mom dad it's me can I stop by real quick
and have a baby
oh yeah not really exactly that it was
your in oh by the way the two-year-old
can you take care of the - yeah I can't
right sandy oh my goodness yes in it's
not all about you I'm trying to get born
here wait what was the question again I
forgot um what was my name or butter
what's your Chipotle order that's the
most important question okay let's
finish on that okay but you know better
than I do
oh okay so you walked into Chipotle okay
there's rice there's beans there's
various no beans
what okay do you miss I get shaken my
lettuce and tricking a lot of salsa
avocado
you mean guacamole yeah god I'm getting
hungry fresh tip okay um fork or spoon
point because of the bowl who eats with
a cell used are you sick I eat with a
spoon everyone I go to pulling with
doesn't eat them oldest kid she's
getting just lettuce and chicken while
he's got to have it
okay lettuce I get but like people who
eat bowls with rice and beans like get
it get a spoon okay like do it the right
way please I like it with a fork there's
only one thing I prefer less since when
opposed mate brings um no utensil to me
it's when they bring a fork instead of
spoon I'd rather no utensil that's
easily remedied you could just say so in
the notes they don't always those
overdose oh that's I hadn't tried should
say alright well mom thank you so much
for joining us is there anything else
you want to like yeah there's me about
or is this good I just can't say enough
how much I appreciate you guys so much
so much you're like my life and you're
very sweet and I love that you wanted me
on here and I love to talk to your fans
there's a lot there's a lot of people
out there watching who genuinely wanted
to meet you so thank you for letting us
meet you I'm so happy to meet you
I hope I get to meet you again yeah
we'll have you won again for sure you
got to catch up to Deb she's at number
three right now three popular chef um my
mom is on she's not very much on social
media but she's on Instagram I will link
for Instagram below if you'd like to
stalk my mother feel free to do so sad
meowing and uh until next time thank you
so much for hanging out mom guys make
sure you check out our sponsor is going
to naturebox.com/tyler annejulien for
two free snacks go to ring calm slash
jet engine for 50 bucks off the ring
security kit but um yeah the best thanks
for coming lambs like this we'll see you
guys next week for another dink fan
podcast